Little Shop of Horrors because I heard
about that and I heard about your
casting in it I I don't think that a
casting match could have been any better
than this so I totally mean I mean the
amount of times I've watched little shop
it was actually in band class whenever
my teacher didn't feel like teaching we
would just sit and watch it on repeat so
it was a love my life
when you approach a voice role like that
how do you find the balance between
honoring levi stubbs but also making the
roll your own well I've known this this
was one of the musicals that is from my
generation from the 80s so I've known it
the songs have been my audition songs
for years and then I was also in the
out-of-town revival tryout before it
went to Broadway back in 2002 and I got
let go from that so I've already played
the voice of the plan and I just
approached it from
the standpoint of what it truly is he's
kind of you know it's kind of like the
Faustian story it's kind of like the
devil story like so you sold me and I'll
give you everything you might he's a
villain and I like I don't get to play
villain it's very awesome
so get ready cuz he's gonna be
everything all of the things I'm gonna
use all the different bridges